well we were at the UFC fight in Miami
and you walked up with uh Trump and that
place lost their mind when you guys walk
I don't know if you
Hey listen
Trump is jumping I don't like people
don't like what Trump is the man
jumping the man he had this fan base he
had his supporters and they got to stick
with him to the end
how has he been to you over the years
hey I always um
and I've had a bad moment with him
you've never had a bad one no no no did
you became very profited from him yet it
was just a great relationship when did
you guys initially meet what was the
first thing it must have been 1920 but I
just ate um I just had dinner with him a
week ago
in Mar-A-Lago where were you in
Mar-A-Lago how was that that was awesome
me him Byron I mean
um Byron and his mother and son Baron
and his mother and it was just off the
hook man um he's so smart the young kid
Baron is smart
seven feet tall now he's six eight but
generally you're very intelligent I I've
heard a lot of weird stories man these
kids they were saying that this is
Artistic this guy is on top of this game
intellectually at 16 years old 17 17 now
got it was Melania there yeah she was
there as well how was the your
interaction with her what is she like
awesomeness like um
the president's wife the First Lady
you have a similar kind of relationship
with the current President Joe Biden I
listen
Ed I didn't have the opportunity to
actually meet President Biden I briefly
met his son Hunter
and um Hey listen we're out here we're
trying to make this the best country we
possibly can and there's certain people
that believe they can do it better and
that's just what this is all about
nothing personal so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you